Tonight is opening night for Disney
Pixar's Alio movie. And this could be
the most satanic movie of all time as of
now. So, let's get into this. Alio, this
is the deep dive. There's a six-minute
video that you guys can share with
people. This is the deep dive because
this movie is so messed up. Notice he's
got the alien gray on his shirt. This is
the first time I've ever seen in a kids
movie where they actually portray an
alien as the way they look to abductees.
Usually they're just like these fantasy
type aliens like the ones you see in the
background there. But he's rocking that
alien head on his shirt. There's a lot
of symbolism in here. We're going to get
into all that. The the dot above the eye
is actually the sun with the Earth orbit
around it. Um he's got one eye going on
here. We're going to look into this
stuff. His name is Alio Soloulless.
Those words both mean something. Can you
guess what it is? Alios Soloulless.
So on the Wikipedia, it actually has a
like a fun fact section and it says both
his name Alio and his surname Solless
mean son. So his name in English is
literally son.
He's the hero of the kids movie and his
name means son. If you know anything
about um paganism and Satan, he's always
trying to get people to worship the sun.
Sun worship is Satan's master disguise.
He loves getting people to worship the
sun. This goes all the way back to
Egypt. Uh you know, Raw and Horus and
all these gods like that. Do you know
how else those gods were represented? A
symbol. We're going to look into that.
So here it says the name Ilio primarily
means son. It's derived from the Greek
god Helios. So this character, this
colorful cartoon character who's the the
hero, his name comes from the Greek god
Helios, the sun god. Solless, his second
name, his last name is a word of Spanish
origin that means son in Latin. And it
can also refer to a surname.
So I'm going to give you multiple um
examples here, multiple pieces of
evidence. This comes from a baby name
site. It says alo meaning sun and it
comes from Helios, which means the sun
god. Here's today during the eclipse,
the solar eclipse, they were saying,
"What are some baby names that have to
do with the sun? And here's some cute
baby names. Alio is on there. Helios,
another Greek sun god. So his name is
the sun god. Solless on the dictionary
it says it means solar.
But if you go to Google translate and
you put Latin in there and you type
solless in Latin, it comes up to Sunday.
I believe there's coming a time when the
governments will force the world to keep
a religion. Keep a one world religion
that is contrary to what God has said.
And we're going to be persecuted if we
say, "No, I will not keep your day. I'm
going to keep the day that God said."
So, Elilio, check it out. He's got this
one eye symbolism going on here. Who is
that? That is Raw, the sun god, or
Horus. Both of them are represented by
one eye. Raw and Horus are the sun god.
Look, I'm not gonna make a big deal off
of one thing. Like, if this whole movie
had nothing to do with sun worship or
any of that, and he had oneeyed cover,
you know, I would think it was sus. But
I wouldn't build a whole presentation
out of it and say, "Look, he's got that
one eye covered, man. That's that one
eye symbolism." But when his name
literally means sun god, Sunday, and
he's got one eye covered like the sun
god, then I think that's significant.
Nothing happens by accident. Nothing in
Hollywood happens by accident,
especially not in animation because
every scene has to be drawn out or or
sculpted. And so nothing happens by
accident.
So Elio Solus, Alios,
it says that he's the ambassador of
planet Earth. So think about that. Who
is the ambassador or leader of Earth
biblically? Let's go to the scriptures.
John 14:30 says, "I will no longer talk
much with you, for the ruler of this
world is coming, and he has nothing in
me." So Jesus is saying, "The ruler of
this world is Satan." John 12:31-33
says, "Now is the judgment of the of
this world. Now the ruler of this world
will be cast out, and I, if I am lifted
up from the earth, will draw all people
to myself." This is he or this he said
signifying by what death he would die.
So again he's saying this ruler of this
world will be cast out. Ephesians 6:12
for we we do not wrestle against flesh
and blood but against principalities
against powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this world. This translation
says age but the King James says world
against spiritual hosts of wickedness in
heavenly places. So Satan works through
the kingdoms the kings and kingdoms of
this world. Satan is the ruler of this
world. John 16:11 says, "Of judgment,
because the ruler of this world is
judged." And 2 Corinthians 4:4 says, "In
whom the god of this world hath blinded
the minds of them which believe not."
This is Satan. Satan is the god of this
world. So here we got the hero of the
movie who's a self-proclaimed
ruler of the world, leader of the world,
ambassador of the world. Very
interesting. Here's some more verses.
Um, Matthew 4 8-9 where Satan is
tempting Jesus in the wilderness and he
says, "If you bow to me, I'll give you
all the kingdoms of the world." Couldn't
have Jesus just said, "What are you
talking about? I rule the world. It's my
world. You can't give it to me." No, he
didn't say that. In Luke 4:5-6, it says,
"Then the devil taking him up on a high
mountain showed him all the kingdoms of
the world. and in a moment of t or in a
moment of time. And the devil said to
him, "All this authority I will give to
you and their glory for this has been
delivered to me and I give it to
whomever I wish." Satan is saying, "The
world belongs to me and I can give it to
whoever I wish. All you got to do is bow
down and worship me." And Jesus said,
"There's no way. I'm not doing that."
But many people have taken that offer
and there are a lot of celebrities and
all that because so many people that's
what they care about the American dream.
I want to be rich and famous and I'll do
whatever it takes. Sell my soul in a
contract. Sure, why not? Many people
have taken that. Job chapter 1 talks
about when
Satan presented himself up in heaven
with the other angels. And I I believe
that he was there representing earth. It
says, "Now there was a day when the sons
of God came to present themselves before
the Lord, and Satan came also among
them. And the Lord said unto Satan,
whence comest thou?" Then Satan answered
the Lord and said, "From going to and
fro in the earth, and from walking up
and down in it." So again, I believe
that this this all proves that Satan is
the god of this world. So, we are still
at 11% towards the goal. $545
towards the goal. If you guys want to
donate, the link is in the description
and it's right here in the chat. Thank
you, Donald, for saying hit that like
button. It really helps to get this
video out in the algorithm so more
people can find out the truth about this
movie, The Dark Truth. So, notice this
is an official Pixar post on X and it
says, "We've all heard the phrase fake
it till you make it." And in Pixar's
final trailer for the upcoming film
Alio, you'll see that phrase in action
as Alio portrays the leader of Earth to
the beings among the galaxy. I mean,
that sounds just like what we just read
in Job, that all these beings from the
galaxy present themselves before the
Lord and Satan is also up there. But
they say that there's a slogan on the
trailer. It says, "Fake it till you make
it." Isn't that what Satan's doing?
Satan is he wants to be like God. He
said, "I will raise my throne to the
heights of the clouds. I will be like
the most high God." He thinks that he is
God. So, he's faking it till he thinks
he's going to make it, but he's never
going to make it. He's going to be
destroyed and turned to ashes. Ezekiel
says, never to be anymore. But I think
it's interesting. All these things are
pointing to Alio is Satan himself.
So who's the villain? Of course, if the
hero is like Satan, then the villain is
like the Lord. Lord Grigon, it's always
like this. This isnosticism. Every time
we see this in a movie where Batman,
he's the the dark knight. He's the god
of the underworld. He's Hades.
And the and the the villains always have
more in common with Christ. Like Twoface
is actually a lawyer. He he upholds the
law. His his hideout has a a big
portrait, a face that looks like Christ
wearing a crown of thorns. And his whole
hideout is shaped like is is uh
furnished like the temple. You got the
animal on a smoking altar. You got the
incense. You got the the seven c the
seven branch candle stand. All of it's
there. So so many of these movies make
the villain like God and this one's no
different. Lord Grigon, what is his
occupation? Is Lord
and he's the galactic ambassador. So
he's the leader of the galaxy. He's
Lord. That's God. Now look, I think it's
interesting that it says family
information. There's no information on
his family except he has one son.
He's got a So the the god of the galaxy
that has one son. Very interesting,
right? Yahweh has a son.
And so I asked I asked Google is does he
try to kill does he try to destroy the
earth? Because that's what Satan always
does. He tries to twist God's character.
He makes it look like God just wants to
destroy everything. He hates your family
and your friends and he's going to come
and destroy the earth with fire. It's
true. He's going to do that. But his
character is not because he's hateful
and he hates your family and friends.
It's because he wants to cleanse the
earth of unrighteousness. He wants to
cleanse the earth of pain and suffering
and misery. But Satan always loves to
twist it. 99% truth is not truth. And I
looked it up and it says that he is
threatening to destroy the home of Alio,
which is Earth. And Gordon's friends,
Gloron's friends are aliens. So these
are demons. Is Christ going to destroy
the home of demons? Yes. Is he going to
destroy the home of alo earth? Yes. He's
going to cleanse it with fire. And it
says earth since Alio is from Earth.
Listen. Listen to this though. Why is he
going to do this? Why does he want to
destroy Earth? He is angry about being
rejected.
Wow. Rejected from the commu
communiverse. So the whole universe, the
communiverse have rejected the Lord. And
it says and he seeks to enact his wrath
against the ambassadors who have turned
him away. I mean this you cannot make
this stuff up. It's using all the
terminology that God is coming with his
wrath to destroy those who reject him,
man. And it says, "The communiverse,
however, prioritizes tolerance and
open-mindedness over military strength,
leading to Grigon's rejection." So, this
is teaching your children that the Lord
of the universe, he's not tolerant, he's
not open-minded. Look, we we have
tolerance. We we appreciate. We love
everybody and we're open-minded and
that's why we reject him and that's why
he's going to come and destroy us. What
is that teaching your children about
God? I'm going to refresh the donation
page here and see if we've moved at all.
645. Thank you so much, guys. We're
getting closer. This is amazing. You
guys are awesome. God bless you all.
Because of your giving, this book can
continue to go out for free. It's going
so far 2,000 copies. 2,000 plus copies
have already went out all over the US.
There's even some in Hawaii. There's
some in Canada. They're going out there
because of you guys. Thank you so much.
So, check out this clip. I think it's
interesting. It actually shows beams of
light, lasers, shooting at the aliens,
which we know are demons, as they all
run away. And Alio is saying, "My
friends, these are my friends that he's
killing." Because in the movie, he
doesn't fit in on in Earth. On Earth,
he's 11 years old. Doesn't every
11-year-old kid feel like they don't fit
in? I'll get into that section, but
let's let's check this out first. Now,
Greg's going to blow everyone up. My
friends need our help. You made a
friend. You will feel my wrath. Gordon.
Hi, Dad. I'm a bargaining chip. Now, say
the other thing. Oh, help me, father.
Quiet you.
What is that unholy sound?
Okay, man. Like I said, there's nothing
by accident. This is crazy. So, the
laser beams are shooting down at the
demons. Notice there's three laser
beams. I think it's very significant.
Three is a a significant number in the
Bible. There's three beams that are
shooting at demons. They're all
scattering. And Alio, who represents
Satan, is saying, "We got to save my
friends.
It's just wrapped up in this pretty
little picture. Then Lord Grigon is
looking down at his son, that hideous
alien maggot with the teeth all down his
body. And Satan is holding him hostage
and al
Lord Grigon, I can't remember these
people's names. The Lord's son says,
"Look, Dad, I'm a bargaining chip."
Isn't that what Jesus was for us? He was
our ransom. Because of him, he took away
the punishment that we deserved.
He He's a bargaining chip. And then when
he tickles the alien,
the Lord of the universe says, "What is
that unholy sound?" Dude, come on.
People don't talk like that unholy
sound. If he was a if he really was an
evil villain, what does he care about
holiness?
Come on, guys. This is so in your face.
You cannot make this stuff up.
So, here's another piece of the clip.
Your life isn't up there, Elio. You need
to make friends. I just want to belong
somewhere. All I ever wanted was to find
a place to fit in. So, if any aliens are
listening, please come and get me. Okay.
Bye. Love you.
It's really happening.
Back home, I didn't fit in. Well, I like
you. It's like I was always meant to be
here.
This puts a holy anger in me when I see
this because you're you're giving a
message about an 11-year-old kid who
feels like he doesn't fit in. What
11year-old actually feels like they fit
in anywhere? You're going through
puberty. You're going through these
weird phases. You're looking at, oh,
there's these cool people. They got
these different uh styles. What is my
style? Who am I?
And because he doesn't fit in, he tries
to summon aliens. He lays out in a field
on a sigil. We're going to look into
what that means, what a sigil is. And
he's out there actively calling for the
aliens to come abduct him. And when they
do, he's like, "It's finally happening.
Wee." And it's like, "This was fun. If
that really happened to somebody in real
life, I guarantee you it's not going to
be a fun experience. you're not going to
be happy because literally you're you're
summoning demons and they're coming to
take you. And when he's talking to this
demon, he's telling him, "Look, I I
didn't feel like I fit in on Earth." And
he says, "Well, I like you. I accept
you." What is that teaching your
children? Look, if you feel like you
don't fit in, go out into a field and
summon the aliens. The demons will
accept you. They'll love you. God
doesn't like you because he's not
open-minded. and and uh whatever. He
wants to destroy you, but the aliens,
oh, they love you and they'll accept
you,
man. So, I asked, "Is it common for 11
year olds to not fit in?" I knew I know
the answer, but I just want to see. Yes.
It's very common for children and
pre-teens to feel like they don't fit
in, especially during periods of
significant social and emotional
development. So, this is targeting kids
that already feel like they don't fit
in. And what's the answer? Just do some
magic. Do some witchcraft and summon
some demons like this. I'm trying to get
abducted by aliens.
Okay. Come and get me. So, remember I
said this movie flips the script. All
these other movies were
an alien crash lands on Earth, which is
interesting. Didn't Didn't uh Lucifer
get cast down to Earth? He was an alien,
a reptile in the garden.
All these movies are about an alien
being that falls to Earth, crashes, and
the kid tries to get them back to their
home planet. And it's this beautiful
story, right? This one is I'm summoning
the aliens to abduct me. I want to be
abducted and I'm going to lay in a sigil
and actively write on there aliens
abduct me. This is exactly what Satan
wants your children to do because Satan
cannot have access into your life unless
you give him permission. There are laws
and rules of engagement that God has
put. And remember, Satan couldn't harm
Job until God said, "Okay, I'll let you
go down there. I'll let you tempt Job."
God has to give permission or we have to
give permission. And how do we do that?
Through all kinds of different things.
We could be listening to satanic music.
We could be watching horror movies. We
could be watching movies like this that
literally make God look like a villain
and demons look like the good guys. We
could be watching this stuff, having
Ouija boards in our home, tarot cards,
Buddha statues,
dream catchers, practicing yoga,
meditation. All these things are telling
the spirit world, "All right, I'm giving
you permission. Come into my life. I'm
actively seeking something. I want to
communicate." And so, when you have a
kid doing this, that's what he's doing.
This is what Satan wants your children
to do. This is what he wants from
everybody. He wants permission to come
into your life. So, we're going to hear
from an expert on History Channel what
this act is, what this ritual practice
is. Check this out. Writer Amy Title
explains the process is part of a new
trend in UFO circles called C5.
C5 is a UFO summoning group. The people
who are involved with C5 use a special
app, certain frequencies and meditation
to try to summon UFOs so they can see
them. Okay. So there is a practice
called C5 which is close encounters of
the fifth kind where they have found out
now people in the euphology movement
have found out that oh if you go into a
field and meditate and and actively say
I want to communicate with you they'll
show up. Now, think about this
logically. Why would a physical being
from a planet millions of light years
away show up because you're in a field
praying?
This is not an alien encounter. This is
spiritual. This is summoning demons. And
people are doing it and they think, "Oh,
we we've come on to something. We found
something. We figured it out." You can
download the app, C5 app, and you can do
it, too. Believe me, if you actively
seek these things, they will show up.
Thank you guys so much. We're at $745
towards the $5,000 goal. Thank you guys
so much for your giving. The link is in
the description. I'll put it here in the
chat.
Thank you guys so much for making Aby's
strange dreams a reality that can be
passed out to children to combat this
message that Disney continues to put
out. So C5, what is it? Um what's this
guy's name again? Stephen Greer. He's
the the guy who started this whole
disclosure project and all that. And you
know, there's these these higherups that
are like, "The people deserve to know
the truth. The government's been
hiding." I used to be right there, man.
I thought I was on to something because
I was watching the alien autopsy and I
was looking at all these misinformation,
disinformation, leaks. The I'm telling
you, there's no such thing as a
whistleblower or a leak on mainstream
media. I saw the the alien autopsy on
Fox, but back then I had no idea that
everything was so controlled. I didn't
know that there was all this spiritual
warfare and disinformation. I just
thought, why are they hiding this? We we
do I want to know the truth. And so I I
was totally sucked into that. I if you
know my testimony, I totally believed in
ghosts and aliens. And because
Christians didn't have the answers to
that subject, I went to the road of the
occult. I went down the road of the
occult because Christians didn't have
answers. And today it's the same thing.
Today, people have more questions than
ever because the military is on the news
having US congressional hearings saying
aliens are real and we talk to them.
They're non-human intelligences. We
don't really know where they come from.
We think they might be interdimensional
beings and they're tell they're talking
to us. So, yes, of course, people are
going to have questions. And when the
church says, you know what, we're not
going to talk about aliens. That's too
strange. it might it might make our
donors feel weird and they're going to
stop donating to our channel or our
ministry.
Um, we can't talk about that. So, we're
doing a disservice
sending people to a road of deception
because the ones who really have the
truth aren't speaking about it. And when
I say the truth, I mean the Bible
literally has the truth in here. I'm
going to look it up. So, Revelation
16:13 says, "I saw three unclean spirits
like frogs." Okay, John is having a a
prophecy of the end of times. He sees
three unclean spirits like frogs. And it
says in the next verse, "For they are
the spirits of devils working miracles."
I mean, Chris Bledsoe said these aliens
healed him of Crohn's disease. working
miracles which go forth unto the kings
of the earth and of the whole world to
gather them to the battle of the great
day of God Almighty.
These beings are coming to the
militaries and the presidents and the
kings of the earth preparing earth to
fight Christ at his second coming.
That's why we have all this propaganda
about oh there's aliens and we need a we
need a space force. We need weapons
pointed towards the heavens to protect
earth from space. We need a golden dome,
Trump says, to protect Earth from some
outside threat from space. All we are
doing is preparing to fight Christ
because these demonic beings in disguise
are going to say, "You know what?
There's an evil alien invader trying to
take over your planet. And that's why
we've come to help you in this battle.
And if you don't side with us, you're
going to you're going to be overtaken.
You're going to be destroyed. And
humanity will side with demons in a
battle against the second coming of
Christ. We are in the end of this thing,
guys. Jesus is coming soon. And the
elites and the militaries of the world
are preparing for it. Whether they're
deceived about it or not, they are
preparing to fight Christ. That's how
close we are to the end of this thing,
guys. Um Steven Greer was the forerunner
of this thing. And it says right here,
meditation and expanded awareness
practitioners
use deep meditation to achieve an
altered state of consciousness believed
to enhance sensitivity to potential
contact with beings who may operate on
higher dimensions. Yeah, fallen angels.
That's exactly what you're communicating
with. C5, there's a whole app you can
get and everything. this is a real
thing. This isn't uh some corner of the
internet, some some weirdo doing this.
These are people who really think, well,
the military is telling us they're real.
I want to communicate with them, too.
And so, Alio, when he gets to the
planet, this outer space planet, he
talks to this like AI
oraoris. Notice this thing is in the
shape of an oraoris. And it's like this
all knowing AI made up of cards. This
shape, this oraoris thing, this is a
gnostic occult symbol. And listen what
it says in the universal users manual. I
contain the secrets of the universe.
When was the last time
somebody approached a serpent who said,
"I can open your eyes. I can I know all
the answers to the universe."
I mean, this is all so satanic. Here's
the definition of this oraoris. It's a
powerful symbol of cyclical time,
eternity, and uh interconnectedness of
all things. This is the phoenix rising
from the ashes. Uh this is all occult
stuff. And you saw the shape it made was
the oraoris. And he claimed to have all
the answers in the universe. Now notice
he's made up of these cards.
These cards have sigils on them. I keep
using this word sigils. What are sigils?
I outlined these symbols that are on
these cards to show you that these are
sigils. Now, listen to what Grant
Morrison, a very highly acclaimed
artist, writer, and artist for DC
Comics, who said that he was writing a
comic about a character based on
himself. And when he drew that the
character broke out in boils, he broke
out in boils. When he drew that the
character was on the verge of dying, he
almost died. until he had an encounter
with what looked like Jesus, except this
being said, "I'm not the God of your
fathers. I'm the stone that breaks all
hearts." He was a Gnostic Jesus. And he
said, "You don't have to die." And he
said, "Well, what do I have to do to not
die?" And this Gnostic Jesus said, "Just
write what we tell you to write and
spread the light." And so this man
writes comic books that demons are
telling him to write in order to stay
alive. I mean, this is it sounds like
sci-fi, but this is reality. This is
spiritual warfare that we're dealing
with right here. Now, listen to what he
said at this convention called uh
disinfo. Yeah, disinfo convention
where he's saying we can all do magic
and it all works. And actually,
Alistister Crowley taught us how to use
sigil magic to summon aliens.
Exactly what this kids movie is teaching
our children. Is there any practicing
magicians in the audience? Put your hand
up if we got any. Yeah. Come on. Bold. A
few. Okay. Okay, by the time we finish
this, you're all going to be practicing
magicians. Like everyone here, we're
trying to figure what's going on. Why do
we feel different? Why don't we fit into
this world? Why do we think that they're
not telling us the truth? So, I went out
and I read Robert Anton Wilson's books
when I was 20 years old. He says, "We
can talk to aliens. We can talk to
people from Syria. Is he talking crap?"
He said, "Alister Crowley's got methods
for contacting alien intelligence and
for changing the world. Is he talking
crap?" So, I did it. And no, he's not
talking crap. and we can all do it. When
I started doing the invisibles, which is
a comic book for people who don't
haven't seen the thing, it's a comic
book which is kind of my attempt to
explain what happened to me after I've
been abducted by aliens in Catmand do in
1994. And the only reason I was abducted
by aliens in Catmoo in 1994 is because I
went to Catmand do in 1994 to be
abducted by aliens. And it works. I
found out that if you do these things
that you're told by Alistister Crowley,
by Wilson, by all these people we read
and all these people we've been
consuming, but we don't do it. If you
actually do what they say, things
happen. And we can all do it. So these
things happen. Magic works. And when I
started doing the comic, I found that
you could actually make magic happen by
writing things and changing the
operating system of the universe. This
magic works. So, I'll tell you something
you can do while I'm here. One of the
best techniques and one of the easiest
techniques to prove that this thing
works is to practice sigil magic. First
thing you do, write down a desire. Make
it something easy that is likely to
happen, something possible. People like
Austin Osman Spear, the magicians from
the early part of the century or Crowley
or the chaos magicians from the 80s who
were big inspiration on me.
They used this stuff. And what you can
do is this. Like I say, try this at
home. Write in a desire. Take out the
vowels and you'll be left with a string
of consonants. Take out the repeated
consonants. You'll be left with a string
of consonants that have no repeats in
it. You know, whatever. X, Y, A, D,
whatever.
Turn that thing into a little image.
Take the D, draw a big D. Then you've
got a T. Draw a T under it. And keep
reducing it down until it looks magical.
And there are no rules for this thing.
Do it until it looks magical. At that
point, you now have a sigil. The sigil
will work. You can project desire into
reality and change reality. It works.
[Applause]
[Music]
This is verifiable. People have been
telling us about this for thousands of
years. You know, the Tibetans have been
telling us about this. The Mesopotamians
have been telling us about this. And why
is it being made occult? Because
Coca-Cola have got the secret. These
people know what we're talking about
here. Because what you do is you create
a sigil.
So, if you didn't catch what he said,
Alistister Crowley taught how to make
sigils to summon aliens. And he drew a
picture of this demon.
Literally, he said it was a demon and it
was it looks just like these aliens. And
so, what this guy is saying is anyone
can do this. He He's He's really adamant
about it. He's like, "Don't just sit
there and listen. Write this stuff down.
Do it." He's like, "It works. If you do
it, it's going to happen. He said, "I
went to Catmand do. I wanted to be
abducted by aliens. I got abducted by
aliens." When you listen to the whole
interview, this thing is over an hour
long. Um, he's talking about how these
beings abducted him and all the the
information they gave him and stuff.
It's all satanic. It's all this sigil
magic garbage. Now, look at this symbol.
He said, "There's no rules. Any you can
make a symbol out of anything."
And then you look at the cards on the
left. The these are the sigils that were
on those cards. And these are sigils on
the right that are common sigils that
come from the book uh the lesser keys of
Solomon and stuff. And we're going to
look at what that stuff means. Look, he
was laying in a sigil. There was cards
with sigils on it. And he was laying in
a sigil to summon demons. Now, does
sigil magic summon demons? Well, he just
said it did. He said Alistister Crowley
said it did. But we'll look further
right here in this magic. Notice it says
sigils is highlighted there. And it it
says
goetic goetic seals from the lesser keys
of Solomon. Look at those sigils. What
do these sigils do? What are they for?
It says a sigil is a type of symbol used
in magic. The term usually refers to a
pictorial signature of a spirit such as
an angel, a demon, or a deity. All
deities are satanic. All these gods that
people worshiped in the past, the Bible
says they are demons. And it says in
modern usage, especially in the context
of chaos magic, a sigil refers to a
symbolic representation of the
practitioner's desired outcome. Just
like he was saying, you want a certain
desired outcome, you make a sigil out of
that thing and it will happen. But what
does it say? It says it's a signature of
a spirit, an angel, a demon, or a deity.
And it says the term sigil derives from
the Latin sigellum
meaning seal. In medieval magic, the
term sigil was commonly used to refer to
occult signs which represent various
angels and demons which the practitioner
might summon.
It's literally telling you that if you
make sigils, you will summon demons.
Now, we have a movie teaching kids, make
a sigil, lay down in it, call upon the
aliens, which are just demons, and guess
what? It'll happen. And they'll love
you, and they'll accept you and and
you'll finally fit in.
This is a lady flipping through a book
of her sigils that she's made to summon
demons and to manifest things into her
life.
So, if we saw the picture on the right,
we would never go for it, right?
Christians would be up in arms. I can't
believe it. Disney made a movie where a
kid's laying in a hexag telling aliens
to come abduct him. But because Disney
was smart enough to use sigils,
something that's less recognizable.
Parents are just like, "Oh, this will be
fun. Let's go see the new movie about
aliens and friendship." been, you know,
it's really trying to help kids that
feel like they don't fit in. There's
nothing about this movie that I can even
get behind. I don't the story or
anything. It's It's so messed up. Now,
what do we see here? What do you guys
see where that arrow is pointing? These
are crystals put in a circle. So, Alio
goes on the rooftop and he puts while
he's wearing the demon face on his shirt
and he puts these crystals in a circle
around him. And here we see that he's in
his treehouse with the crystals around
him in a circle and an alien face on his
vision board because that's another way
of manifesting and this law of
attraction and all that is you have a
board and you write what you want to
summon on that board. He has the picture
of a UFO and a and an alien demon face
as he's on his knees
praying
talking to the demons on a CB radio
calling out to them.
Would you ever allow your child to put a
bunch of crystals around them, put a
demon on a vision board and get on some
kind of technology and say, "Demons,
come. I I want to talk to you. I want
you to be my friends. No way. Yet, it's
all in this subtle disguise that these
are just cute little alien friends.
But this is a a common practice in the
new age to put these crystals in a
circle around you because they believe
that crystals have power to communicate.
If you've ever um seen Radio Shack, I
know that's really old thing, but you
can order these things on on the
internet called a crystal radio and you
can take a crystal and you can hook
speakers to it and it'll without power
it'll actually pick up radio stations
because I don't know. I don't know how
it's done. It's it's God's
stones that do some cool stuff, but
Satan has hijacked everything of God to
where it's like, "No, you can actually
communicate with spirits through
crystals. Just sit in a circle of them,
just like the movie Alio teaches you."
Who is Alistister Crowley? That's This
is the guy that we just saw the bald guy
talking about. His name is Grant
Morrison, and he's talking about
Alistister Crowley, how he talked about
this sigil magic, how he can summon
aliens, and what is on his forehead? The
allseeing eye of Horus. The same symbol
that showed up in that video. The same
symbol that Alio is representing while
he has one eye covered and he represents
the sun god Sunday and all this stuff.
Alistister Crowley wrote a book and in
that book he drew a picture literally of
the demon that he was manifesting and
speaking to on a regular basis and it
looked just like this. It looks just
like the head that's on Alio's shirt.
This these are the beings that are
abducting people who allow Satan to have
access into their life because of yoga
and tarot cards and uh meditation,
guided meditation,
when you start speaking to ascended
masters and all these things. When you
participate in this stuff or when you're
sitting down and watching a movie that
is literally about summoning demons with
crystals
and sigils,
you are allowing Satan into your life.
And this movie is going to be this movie
is so candycoded that so many even
Christian families are going to go to
that theater and they're going to walk
away with something attached to them.
Now, you can go to a Disney park right
now and they have all this Alio stuff.
And I think it's interesting that Alio
is saying uh or it says, "Welcome to
Alio's guide to an interactive
adventure." Now, when I see that word
guide, my mind goes straight to like
guided meditation, spirit guides, all
that stuff. I think it's an interesting
word. But here to enter into the the
room here, you have to walk through the
portal. That portal is is the UFO beam
that abducted Alio in the movie. So you
have to this is an interactive Bible
study for Satan. There was a game called
um Shin Magami Teni. And in the game,
you literally fight Yahweh. His name,
the the villain, the final boss is this
golden face and his name is Yahweh. And
as you're going up flights of stairs to
fight him, because you have to fight him
in heaven, every time you get to a
doorway on those steps, it asks you a
question. It says, "Do you wish to
proceed?" And you have to choose yes or
no. Yes. The whole time you're going up
the stairs, Yahweh is saying, "Please
don't do this. I'm begging you. Repent.
I don't want to destroy you." all these
things and you have and the next step,
the next doorway says or while you're
fighting him, a demon pops up on screen
and says, "We figured out that rejecting
him destroys him." And so it it
interactively pops up on screen. Do you
wish to reject Yahweh? Yes or no? Guess
what? If you hit no, you don't win the
game. To win the game, you have to
actively select yes, I reject Yahweh.
Anytime you do a Bible study with
somebody and you're teaching them all
these new truths about the Bible, about
baptism and what happens when you die
and keeping the Sabbath and all these
things, all these new truths,
you're trying to get them to a point at
the end where they say, "Yes, I see the
truth and I want to from here on keep
this. I want to walk this out." And so
Satan's doing the same thing with these
games. Do you wish to reject Yahweh? Yes
or no? Now you got this room where it's
like enter in through the portal
and you'll be taken on a fun adventure
because it says here you can let the
demons I mean aliens remember aliens are
just demons. So here you can let the
demons know you're ready for the
ultimate space adventure. Oh, and don't
forget to smile. Teaching your children,
make sure you smile as you summon the
demons. and you go over here to a wall
with a sigil on it and the parents are
like, "Oh, go go go over there, Johnny.
I want to take a picture of you in front
of the little sigil."
And so now parents are actively getting
their children to lay on a sigil and
capture the moment and me and with a
sign that says, "Aliens abduct me." And
then they'll say next, "Oh, go over
there in the alien beam. I want to take
a picture of you, Susie. Now open your
arms and look happy like Alio did. Yay,
you're being abducted by the demons and
you're vicariously
acting the whole thing out like
roleplaying. This is literally
roleplaying how to be abducted by demons
right here at Disney.
It says adventures are on the way.
Uh more amazing. Wait, adventures are
way more advanc. I'm sorry. Adventures
are way more amazing with a partner.
That's me and my bestest space bud
glored on. So he's saying, "Look, to
have fun. You need a demon with you.
Look at mine. Look at my demon friend
with teeth all throughout his body.
Doesn't he look cute and friendly,
man? This is This is It angers me. Thank
you so much, guys. We reached $1,000
towards our $5,000 goal. You guys are
awesome. We're getting to the end of
this presentation. In 30 minutes, I have
to be giving a presentation on a Zoom,
so I have to wrap this up pretty quick.
But I believe that God will provide and
we'll make the $5,000 so that this book
can stay free and we can pass it out to
all the children out there. So, here it
is. More amazing adventure with a demon
friend. Then it says, "There are so many
cool demons to hang out with in the
communiverse.
Zoom on over and say hi." And so when
you zoom over, you are faced with these
hideous demons
that they call alien friends. And
they're so cool, right? I mean, I I see
right through this propaganda, and it
just breaks my heart. It blows my mind
that people aren't catching on. Like
Satan has been so subtle over the years
with ET and all this stuff that we can't
even see it anymore. Christians have
lost all discernment. We we're not
researching. We're not testing the
spirits. We don't know what's going on.
And we're literally paying to set our
kids in front of this garbage that's
teaching them sigil magic, crystal
magic, and how to summon demons all
under the guise of Disney Pixar colorful
fun.
If you've never seen Roger Morno, I want
you to pay attention to what he says
here because he was in a demon
worshshiping cult. And he said, now that
that video is from the '9s, the video
we're about to watch is from the '9s.
And he's thinking about something that
happened 40 years prior. And he said 40
years ago, the satanic high priest said,
"I want to tell you how Satan's going to
deceive the world." And he said he's
going to do it in a unique manner.
First, he said there's going to be a
time of calamity and chaos and pandemics
and all these things when new age is on
the rise and pandemics and earthquakes
and all that. We're there, guys. During
this time,
demons are going to come and say, "We
need to keep Sunday holy." And they're
going to come in the form of aliens.
Check this out.
The priest said
that as the times on this planet gets
more and more difficult
and calamities of all kinds are striking
the planet more and more frequently.
Demon spirits are going to
impress people with with the the
importance of Sunday sacredness.
And he said it's going to be done in a
unique manner because he says spirits,
demon spirits will
declare themselves to be inhabitants of
far distant planets in the galaxies
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet earth of the impending
destruction of the planet unless
something seriously
proper is done to avoid it.
Isn't that crazy? We're literally living
in that time right now. We're thousand
dollars, guys. Thank you so much. God
bless you guys. We cannot do this
ministry without you guys. I don't know
how real that is to you guys. I don't
know how to thank you enough because we
walked away, Aubrey and I walked away
from a steady paycheck to do what we
believe God has called us to do. To
speak out on things that nobody else is
talking out again about. There's strange
normal. There's little light. There's
there's lots of people talking about
things that aren't being talked about,
which I love. But I believe that we are
doing something that God has called us
to do. And and we don't have to answer
to anybody and say, "Hey, I feel like we
should talk about this topic, can I?"
Now, we can just talk about it. We can
go live anytime we want to. And this has
been almost 12 months now. And God has
provided since month one. since month
one, enough to make our mortgage. Then
it was like the next month mortgage and
bills. The next month it was like
mortgage, bills, and groceries. But I
don't know how to explain this to you
guys without getting just super candid.
We depend on donations to survive, to
keep doing this channel, and it's all
because of you guys. I wish that I could
tell you guys more how thankful I am. I
wish I could make a I'm going to work on
like making a credits page to thank all
our Patreon donors and our donors. I
haven't had time. We've been racing
around like crazy traveling and just
trying to keep content flowing on here
for you guys. And this book, I mean,
this took a lot of work to make this
book a reality. And it really, honestly,
it took two years to become a physical
thing. But I I believe God's timing is
perfect. When that book came out, it was
right when the military is saying, "Yep,
we talked to non we talked to non-human
intelligences." And now this movie is
coming out and this is the perfect time
for this book. So if you guys believe in
the message, if you believe in fighting
against what Disney is spending millions
of dollars propagating to your children,
we cannot thank you enough. Look, if
you're subscribed to Disney Plus or Hulu
or all those things, I would really take
that to prayer and ask, "Do we need to
cancel this stuff?" I I see Christians
throw their money at Hollywood into all
this garbage and yet when it comes to a
fellow believer saying, "Hey, we need
your help." It's like, "Ah, all you guys
care about is money. Look, we're our our
YouTube channel's not even monetized.
We've been rejected twice by YouTube for
harmful content. We're not making any
money. We're not showing you ads or
anything. I'm just getting super candid
with you guys. I want you to know that
your support means the world to us and
we love you guys and we can't thank you
guys enough. And this is the last slide
right here. Exactly what Roger Monno
said that in the last days, aliens,
demons in disguise as aliens are going
to push Sunday sacredness. And this
hero's name is Sun God Sunday. And it's
all about summoning aliens because
they're our friends.
I believe time is short. I believe we
are wrapping this whole thing up and
that Jesus is coming soon. Notice that
Alio is Helios and the sun god Horus and
all that stuff.
If you guys believe that too, please
click a thumbs up. It really helps get
this message out to the world. It's a
easy free way to support this ministry.
If you would like to support this
ministry through donations, you can do
so by going to candidtruth.org. We got
Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. When you
go to the donate page, you'll see um
ways to wire money to this ministry. If
you like t-shirts and you actually want
to get something back for your donation,
we get $5 on pretty much everything
that's sold, whether it's a shirt or a
hoodie or whatever, go to our website,
click shop, and buy one of the shirts
there. That really helps support this
ministry. And if you want to support
this book
that I think is so important and I know
hundreds of other people think it's
important too because they're ordering
it for the kids at their church. You
guys go to candidtruth.org
and
click
merch and click the book and get your
free copy of this book. If you get one,
it's going to cost five bucks to send
one. That's just the way media mail
works. But you can get like 50 books for
10 bucks. You can buy a hundred books
for like 20 or 30 bucks and you can give
them to every kid on your block at your
church at some event that's going on.
Pass this book out like wildfire because
people need to know the truth,
especially our youth about what's
coming. I don't think we are ready. We
are at $1,000, guys. God's going to
provide. He will provide. We cannot
thank you guys enough.
God bless you. We love you. We thank
you. Thank you so much for being here.
We'll see you next time on Candid Truth.